my boy uh oh my god chappelle won't shut
up about this guy
this guy we're on the road we just sit
in the airbnb and watch youtube videos
and chappelle brought up this guy what's
his name shinigami
he is the best thing wait do you see
this guy now brian i'm gonna ask you
before you see it
do you when you do see him do you think
he's got this guy no go to no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
youtube champions instagram what does it
can't wait to see him shinigami
shinigami
uh
street beefs there it is shinigami go to
that one that top one go to this come on
this is how this is exactly what i kick
looks like a bad taekwondo no
no no no no no no no
yeah get ready keep talking that [ __ ]
that's the belly hills ninjas
talking that [ __ ] keep that same energy
that same energy
now they're fighting on hay but be cool
yeah be cool
now it's a good bro and they put out hay
okay no now notice he has a black belt
on and a bandana
because he's a black belt wow watch
brian watch him work
for his size that's what happened to him
he's a big kid
that's taekwondo there you go boom come
on brian
front foot that's a tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
i love watching street beasts because
they're like shout out to my sponsors
and they're like
shout out to my kids wife friend andrew
what's up dog told you i was gonna make
it man here we go here and he's and he
always bows
uh i don't know who that is yeah no i'm
not i'm not gonna lie a lot yeah
he fights a lot invites a lot now it
gets a little dicey if it goes past a
minute because if it goes all right now
yeah that's the thing about
spoiler alert bad cardio cardio
cardiovascular
strong asset did you guys watch the
fights this weekend oh [ __ ] of course
okay well here who uh that [ __ ]
fight yeah [ __ ] the pros
we're talking about that not sure what
to do here with the single legs
he's trying to look at him look at him
hey watch it watch him work
oh boy but look what he did oh oh
kimura no oh there you go oh nice all
right
here we are now they're they're they're
fighting on straight on this stuff yeah
on ground it's good to get it in your
skin too it's there no no tetanus
oh just oh no they keep going chin fast
forward it you
this is the thing about him it's either
a knockout or it's very boring
there's no in between hey i can
literally watch his fights all day
okay he lost due to oh no that's like
his first loss i think it's his only
loss it's like matt sergey you know what
though i think he's i think he's like 20
and one he lost a big screen i'd say
he's kidding
at least shinigami isn't he great is he
great
he's getting in there you're great thank
you i i give him i support him he's
fighting he's really fighting i get
anybody who gets into a [ __ ]
pit like i found out he sells merch too
and me and chappelle are gonna buy
something oh yeah i'm buying this
headband i 100 want a t-shirt you guys
should probably maybe i should get my
food truck wait what's his instagram
not a lot of people find it yeah but he
should i like him isn't he great yeah oh
he's
he's amazing i like him shinny 61 000.
um the wrong guy shinigami
it's verified he's not verified he's
faking it
go to the youtube clip again i think it
says on there what does shinigami mean
yeah what does that mean that first top
one good good job knowing it's japanese
i think it means out of shape
that's a nice thing i'm going to do my
boy like that
there's this person they might be
following him
let's see we're not following them they
yeah they should be following
yeah of course they're falling [ __ ]
again dude and where do they do these at
i would love to know
you said lancaster i would love to go to
one
uh yeah yeah of course because you
wouldn't get mobbed at all
because you wouldn't have to take all
the pictures yeah right because you love
that i know he has this definitely go to
one
yeah definitely go maybe i could go in
like a disguise
there he is there's my boy the reaper
the reverb the reaper mma he just cooked
steaks too
oh it you know of course it's thick
but you got to love a guy who could give
a [ __ ] about like his
weight loss he's just like i'm a
heavyweight uh turn it up chip
trains they got me back again still here
at the lab with a very important
birthday shout out to team shinigami con
zones
he's always giving shout outs 21st
birthday bro hell yeah bro get lit and
have fun in vegas bro
yeah bro uh bet it all on black
seems
it looks like he's related to her yeah
how dare you
having lunch with the rachel much
overdue movie and lunch dave how about
you that's his girl
how dare you girl
just wanted to make a quick announcement
that i somehow have
twice as many followers on instagram as
i have subscribers on youtube
please make sure you go subscribe to my
youtube link is in my bio or you can
just look me up it shouldn't give me the
reaper
okay dude he sounds like a lot a lot of
food a lot of
this so what is it dude i swear to god
i'll buy that shirt yeah
that might be my next tattoo even though
i never got sick you don't have a tattoo
though no but i like i like his hair oh
i like it you gotta love a dude who just
get like he gets let's
hang out he gets in there and fights a
real kung fu panda the streets
but like he's a street panda here's the
thing he's
no just street panda mma oh look at him
dude dude he's amazing listen i couldn't
pull off that kick oh gina
back in the day 2015. oh this guy's in
it to win it
i mean that's gotta be his girl that's
the throwback yeah that's his game hey
shinigami rachel again with another
birthday shout out to
danny and jose hope you guys have a
blast
on this amazing occasion i wish i was a
new year's baby
[Laughter]
awesome hey you gotta love them you
gotta love them
happy new years from the shinigami
family hey
hey happy new year so he's got kids he's
got kids well she has a pentagon tattoo
so that's cool
i think that we have to be careful about
celebrating a satanist
they're not satanists well you wouldn't
get that that too if you don't get down
with that stuff
why would you why because some people
like the way it looks okay some people
like human sacrifice
don't you and some people like the nazis
how dare you treat shinigami
i don't know i don't judge if that's
what they're into i don't give a [ __ ]
is she's she's she's into the darkness
no i'm gonna have to see what's going on
and
if there's any sacrifice going on and
also um
hey does it there's a heavyweight uh
limit like
265 it's stopping he's not fighting at
265. uh he's probably 265. no no
remember he thought you were 265. now
think how much he is true he's over
three right
i spend way too much time in my brain
yeah spent way too much my brain
in tampa uh thinking about you at 19.
i'm gonna need you to trim down i can't
there is a [ __ ] when
when michelangelo carved the statue of
david
okay still stand stay in florence it is
you know one of the wonders
of the one he said he looked at that
piece of marble he looked that piece of
model he called it garnet
it's meat you know what he said he goes
it's in there
the perfect body is in there it's in
your mouth i just got to get all the
meat you know what i do
now though you didn't see how much
weight he was pushing
dude go to my instagram what'd you do to
go to my store 45